- What?
I got an 80.
That's ridiculous.
Hey guys, I'm back at it.
And as you know from the
position that I'm sitting in,
I'm about to do something on the computer.
And that's take a kid's health quiz.
Because I've taken an idiot
test before and I failed.
You recommended that I do
Buzzfeed medical quizzes
and I think those are gonna be too hard.
So I took on something my
own level, kid's health.
I'm talking about a
health quiz for children.
If with my doctorate degrees
I can't get 100 on all of
these, I should be embarrassed.
I kind of have a feeling I will be.
(mellow music)
How much do you know about the heart?
Find out by taking this quiz.
And again, this is meant to be for kids.
How many chambers does the heart have?
The heart has four chambers.
Two Atria, two ventricles.
Atria are on top,
ventricles are on bottom.
Watch this, bam.
All right, they don't even tell you
if I got it right or wrong or
not. Let's see what happens.
The movement of blood
through the heart and body
is called circulation, locomotion,
ventriculation, or a heart pump.
This is a pretty easy one.
Locomotion is what a train does.
Ventriculation sounds like something
your ventricles might do.
Heart pump, no idea.
Circulation, A.
- Final answer.
- Okay, question number three.
The beating sound your
heart makes comes from
blood going in the wrong direction.
That sounds problematic.
B, valves closing. Hmm.
C, the heart skipping beats.
Your ears playing tricks on you.
It's valves closing.
Lub dub, lub dub, lub dub.
With circulation, the heart
provides your body with:
oxygen, nutrients, a
way to get rid of waste,
or all of the above.
Well let's take these one at a time.
Oxygen.
All of the cells in your
body require oxygen.
Nutrients.
All of the cells in your
body require nutrients.
Getting rid of waste.
Every time your body
makes use of a nutrient,
there's always a waste product.
How are you gonna get
rid of it? Your kidneys.
How are they gonna get there?
Blood.
I love blood.
The atria are the upstairs
chambers of the heart
and these parts are the
downstairs chambers.
Well like we said earlier,
that the atria up top
ventricles chilling on the bottom bunk.
I wanna go with B, ventricles.
- Final answer.
- Question six, what wall
separates the left side
and the right side of the heart?
The ventricle, which we
just said is the basement
the atrium, which we
just called the attic.
The septum, I'm not gonna get into.
And the great wall is
what's found in China.
So I'm going C, septum, final answer.
Question seven.
What parts act like the doors that control
blood flow in the heart?
Heart dams?
Heart dam.
Kidneys.
Chambers.
Yeah, it's valves.
Final answer.
What organ removes waste from the blood?
The heart.
Well we all know the heart
pumps blood, it's a muscle.
So it aint removing waste.
Lungs.
Kinda, so this is kinda a trick question.
Because CO2 is kind of waste.
Kidneys.
Final answer, they remove waste.
You can keep your heart strong by
eating heart-shaped candy.
Doing activities like playing outside,
riding your bike, and swimming.
C, smoking.
D, sleeping 18 hours a day.
Playing outside, riding
your bike and swimming.
What are the tubes that carry blood
back to the heart called?
Tubas, pipes.
B, veins.
A, arteries.
A, carry blood away,
veins bring blood back.
What's the difference
between arteries and veins?
Well, veins are thin-walled,
arteries are more muscular.
Why?
Cause arteries sort of
need to help contract
and push that blood away from the heart.
Veins are sort of just tubes
that allow blood to go back.
And they have valves inside of them.
So each time the heart pumps
they open, then the blood
so it doesn't fall back
down, the valves close.
I got a hundred, I got
a hundred on a kids quiz
with a doctorate.
If I get one of these wrong you guys
can jump me in the comments section.
Muscles quiz.
Come on.
Let's do it.
The three major types of
muscles in the body are:
smooth muscle, sports
muscle, cardiac muscle,
running muscle, and flexible muscle.
The answer is B, smooth
muscle, cardiac muscle,
and skeletal muscle.
Two, the muscle that pumps
blood throughout your body is:
the heart, cardiac.
Which muscle helps you
move your shoulders?
Let's talk about it.
Smooth muscle, where is that found?
Not in your shoulders,
that's not skeletal muscle.
Smooth muscle is like in your stomach.
Quadriceps, you know where that is?
In your legs, in your upper thighs.
Tendons are what muscles
use to attach to bone,
as opposed to ligaments,
which attach bones to bones.
Deltoid muscle are the little
caps around your shoulders
that helps move your shoulders.
Which type of muscle is found
in your digestive system?
Oops, gave it away.
Smooth muscle, yeah.
What connects bones and muscles together?
God, I'm giving all of them away.
Tendons, oh it says glue.
Albert?
Skeletal muscles work with
bones to give your body:
Strength?
The ability to move?
Strength and the ability to move.
None of the above.
Skeletal muscles give you
strength and the ability to move.
Yeah.
Some of your biggest and
most powerful muscles are:
In your calves and thighs.
In you back near your spine.
In your arms, or in your fingers.
The strongest muscle in
your body is your calf.
Its been measured scientifically.
The answer is calves and thighs.
Which muscles are found in
the front of your thighs?
Quads, biceps, pecs, or deltoids.
Let's start with bottom-up
as we've done before.
Deltoids, shoulder caps.
Pecs, boom.
Biceps, boom.
Quadriceps, front of your thighs.
Which muscles are found in your belly
and sometimes called abs.
They're called abs because
the proper medical term
for them is rectus abodominus.
When you make a muscle in your
arm, you are flexing your:
Biceps.
And you know why the bicep is called bicep
and the tricep is called the tricep?
It's cause there's multiple heads.
So the bicep has two heads,
the tricep has three heads
and the quads have four heads.
What, I got an eighty!
That's ridiculous!
They said the most powerful
muscles are in your spine.
That is a lie.
- Liar.
- I've seen the study that your gastroc
is your strongest muscle.
I'm pulling up the study right
now before I lose my mind.
Hold on a second.
I definitely misclicked on something.
Yeah wait where's the
other one I got wrong?
I only got one wrong
why did I get an eighty?
Number one, right.
Number two, right.
Number three, right.
Number four right.
Number five, right.
Number six, right.
Number seven, wrong.
Number eight, right.
Number nine, right.
And number ten right.
What is this game cheating me?
This is ridiculous.
Strongest muscle, your
gonna see a couple things.
Your gonna see the tongue,
and then the gastroc.
The muscle that can pull
with the greatest force,
this is a government website by the way,
I'm gonna pull this up
just to make it very clear.
There is no one answer
for the strongest muscle
in the human body since
there are different ways.
The muscle that can pull
up, can pull with the
greatest force is the soleus.
It is found below the gastroc calf muscle.
The soleus is very important for
walking, running and dancing.
It's considered a very
powerful muscle along
with calf muscles because
it pulls against the force
of gravity to keep the body upright.
Now, the other one is the gluteus maximus
which is obviously the thigh.
It's the largest muscle in the human body
and it's a large powerful muscle
because it has the job
of keeping the trunk
in an erect body posture.
So, if we have the gluteus on this list
and we have the soleus,
where in the world is spine?
I want my hundred.
Editors of the site, give me my hundred.
Ridiculous.
All right, which next,
which should be the next one
that I do.
- Do better bro.
- Are you serious?
Sorry, don't worry about it.
Let's do the digestive system.
Q one, how long is an
adults small intestine?
God, these are hard.
Thirty miles?
Thirty inches.
Twenty two feet is ridiculous.
It's not seventeen feet either.
Could it be seventeen feet, no way.
I'm going with thirty inches.
The digestive process starts in:
The bathroom.
- Do NOT go in there.
- Uh it actually starts in the mouth
with your teeth doing all the chomping
and the saliva doing the digestion.
The liver's role is to:
Mash up food, no.
Turn water into food.
That's like a Jesus thing.
C, help the stomach.
Sounds legit.
Remove harmful substances from the blood.
That sounds more legit.
You know like alcohol and Tylenol.
Ou, I'm rhyming today.
God, I'm on a role.
Oh my God, how many things am I gonna say
that rhyme with taking a poll.
God, please don't jump into
the comments and troll.
[Gasps] Okay I don't have
any more I'm sorry I ran out.
Dan do you got any more?
- This is out of control.
- This is getting out of control, exactly.
Question four, when they
reach the stomach, mashed..
when they.. assuming
they're referring to the
mashed up food particles.
They mix with guava juice.
Well if you drink guava juice, then maybe.
Gastric juices.
Mucus.
Or bile.
Mucus sounds gross, but I
think gastric means stomach.
And if we're saying when
they reach the stomach
they mix with stomach juices.
B, final answer, gastric means stomach.
Bile is made in the:
Large intestine, no.
Stomach, no.
Liver, yes.
All of the above, no.
What does the digestive system do?
Breaks down and handles food.
Pumps blood throughout the body.
Okay, if your kid thinks
your digestive system
pumps blood, we got a problem.
C, helps you breathe.
The digestive system aint
helpin' you breathe, it digests.
Helps your arms and legs move.
It technically could be D.
And I'm one of those, yeah
I'm one of those people that
argues questions on tests.
But think about it, if you
don't get enough nutrients
from your food, can you
move your arms and legs?
Can you breathe?
Can you pump blood throughout
the rest of your body?
I don't think so.
Technically all of the above.
Your food can spend up to this
long in the small intestine:
so they have four years.
Four seconds.
Four minutes.
I'm gonna go four hours.
What tube moves food from the back
of your throat to the stomach?
The esophagus.
Which organs help with the
absorption of nutrients?
Pancreas, liver, gallbladder.
Liver, heart, and spleen.
Well, first of all the heart
is not a digestive organ
let's get that out.
The gallbladder, kidneys, appendix.
No because if we get rid of
the appendix we're all good.
Kidneys, liver, bladder.
Well the bladder definitely
doesn't do any absorption.
So we can go ahead and put
pancreas, liver, gallbladder.
The large intestine measures about:
one-foot long, ten-foot long,
five-foot long, hundred-foot long.
I'm gonna say five feet.
I got a ninety again.
Oh you're quiet now.
If I turn around are you gonna get wise?
I got the first question wrong.
How long is an adult small intestine.
The answer is twenty-two feet.
I should've known this.
I made a playlist for you of
my funniest gaming videos.
Click here to check it out.